who are you as an individual that pulls
for somebody to be withdrawn or
more self-expressed and and i can
remember talking to one of my managers
for
an mlb team and we had a little incident
in the clubhouse
where one of our sort of all-star
pitchers spoke to the media about
a subject that was clearly really meant
to be in-house
you know sort of in the confines of the
locker room
and so the manager was kind of pissed
you know and upset that this had now
gone through a journalist and was sort
of out there in the public domain
and so he was looking directly at the
picture from the perspective of judgment
and criticism like he is the cause of my
suffering and my frustration which is
how most people react to life right like
i'm upset because of what they did or
what happened
which is all the illusion and i said
okay well i understand where you're
coming from and i get that you're upset
but can i ask you a few questions
so i could get into his world right so
i'm listening he's like sure i said
tell me a little bit about your
relationship with the pitcher
he's like what do you mean i said well
to what degree do you think
you hold a space that is safe and open
and inviting for him to come to you and
you know he was
kudos to him he was honest he said well
we don't have the best relationship and
you know and i cited a couple of intro
altercations they'd had earlier in the
season he's like yeah i mean i was
pretty hard on him and
whatever and i said so could you see
that perhaps
when it relates to a topic that for him
is heartfelt because it was a sensitive
issue
where is your role in recognizing that
he felt more comfortable talking to a
journalist than he did to you
and that's where he became a better
manager at that moment i said so maybe
your opportunity
is to use this as a catalyst to see that
perhaps as a leader which you are as the
manager of this clubhouse
your capacity to listen isn't as great
as perhaps you might
proclaim it to be and you can clean it
up with him and say hey
thank you for showing me that i perhaps
am not the greatest listener for you and
i'd like to change that
so then he became a better leader so
with regards to people being withdrawn
we could say more depressed or somebody
being overly verbose or anxious
i would say yes some of that's generated
by virtue of their conditioning but it's
also based on the environment they're
speaking
into and so that's where people
really have some say in the way that a
relationship
goes because we often think well the
relationship i have with that person is
over there with them
you know whether they're a nice person
or a bad person or however you want to
declare it
but the relationship is actually with us
because the way we view someone
is the container within which we
communicate to them so if you're like oh
bob he's awesome you know it's like
you talk to bob from a position of like
that's a human being who's awesome
if you know mary is a pain in my ass
then you speak to mary from that
position but the relationship of
mary exists within our own perception
right
so that's where you start to see and
this goes back full question of you know
full circle to your point about
like how do we experience everyone well
it's all us you know
so like you're awesome because you know
that's how i see you which is really me
so i'm awesome
right but we don't see things as there
we see things as we are
exactly so yeah it gets it gets it gets
pretty deep i like that we've gone there
straight away here
um i want to talk about listening
because like
there's got to be more rules to it right
because there's one thing of just sort
of listening
yeah but i can just sit here and listen
you talk the whole time and say
i listen to you yeah okay there's got to
be more participation than that
to being a good listener right there's
got to be more
to it than just sitting there and
listening is it repeating back
is it asking more questions is it like
how
what is it what is a good listener
so now it's a great question i would
just subtly change again because of
words and we're being specific there's
you don't got to do anything right
because gotta have to should supposed to
must all of those words carry resistance
like
i gotta do this and i gotta do i've
gotta finish my homework and i
must do this and i've gotta like none of
those words are empowering
like they're all disempowering so
there's no gotta and i would say that if
you're listening from a position of that
then you've already put
a barrier because it's sort of an
implied like task
now i have to listen to my mother-in-law
or
i should you know i have to listen to my
boss
so i would sort of get rid of any
resistance first of all and it wants to
be an action of love i would say and
that would be one of the undercurrents
that is imperative in order to be
powerful listening
is that not only am i hearing like the
the physics of my
my my ear sensing sound
but i'm getting what you're saying that
would be the the deeper undertaking
which is to really get
you know because you could start telling
me about something that's troubling in
your life right now
and if i didn't have the undercurrent of
sympathy empathy or the ability to
relate to that
then i might be hearing what you're
saying but i'm not really understanding
the depth of your own pain
so listening is where it's a container a
safe space where i'm also
understanding the depth of your reality
it could be joy it could be misery it
could be heartache it could be grief
and of course i get to do this a lot
because people are telling me whatever's
going on in their life and invariably
invariably if they're coming to see me
it's because things are a bit
problematic it's not always the case
like you know a lot of my athletes and
high performers are thriving but they
know they could go to another level so
it's not necessarily something like some
malaise or their
life isn't this dark place but to be
able to really get
like the the depth of despair that
people feel like really understand how
scared someone is like that would be
sort of listening x right that would be
listening like where you really are
holding space embodying in your own
experience the degree to which you can
somebody else's reality that's
connection
that's that's resonance so putting
yourself there to some degree
to really to embody means to feel it
right so going to a place where you felt
fear or you felt sad
yeah to be able to ra relate to them at
that level of emotion and that's where
we talk about empathy and sympathy and i
think that also comes with
um maturity right it would be very
difficult
my mom died when i was seven it's going
to be very difficult for me as a
seven-year-old to have empathy for my
dad's experience of losing his wife
you know because i don't have the
wherewithal i don't have the bandwidth
to understand i haven't gone through my
own grief of someone who i love dying of
course my mom but at seven i don't
process that as a seven-year-old so
and i think that's also where there's a
lot of compassion with somebody's
inability to listen like that's just
where they're at you know and that's a
hard
pill to swallow when you're in a
relationship that perhaps where somebody
is evolving and they're a better
listener and perhaps their partner isn't
so good
but it also might just point to the fact
that maybe they haven't had so many
experiences
on the sort of the tapestry of human
emotion so they're unable to relate
fully to what someone's going through so
when you go through
experiencing a new emotion as you said
they maybe haven't experienced that
before
are you remembering how it feels or are
you
actually getting the feeling for the
first time let me back up by saying
yeah as a as a as a concept i believe
that
we kind of we are everything
we are the universe within outside
so within so without as above so below
we're the whole
thing yeah so it's more about
remembering the feeling of familiarity
and that
we have we have it inside of us which is
why we can feel it
um so do we actually have to get the ex
like how do we get there how do i like
you know what i mean how do we get to
relate to someone
do we actually have to have the
experience um
no i think that could be helpful in
terms of a visceral
experience but it can be just purely
like the
sentience the understanding the
resonance of it
so i think it is a remembrance right
like and i think one of the reasons we
have the world of
perceived separation and diversity is
that
you know going deeper again like
what is consciousness right like so
one of my quotes i love that we just
came straight into the deep stuff
i say you know the seeker is the sort
right like which people are going to
have to
like s-o-u-g-h-t not i was like the
sword i'm like trying to imagine the
seeker is the sword
so what the the sought the sod the sword
yeah baby uh the the seeker is the sort
so what does that mean so you know the
essence of who i am
is that which i seek so we could say
that consciousness is just wanting to
know itself
but and and i had this as an actual
experience
when i was my little rent control
apartment in santa monica this is
you know prior to sort of what i could
say was a big shift i don't want to call
it my awakening that sounds very
pretentious but
where i at least shifted gears in the
way that i related to myself as a human
being
i was just going for a run or just come
back for a run
and i was leaning up against the wall
stretching one of my calves
so you know my foot was back you've done
this i'm sure many times and so my face
is close to the wall so i get a little
bit of an angle and i'm stretching my
achilles
and by virtue of the fact that my face
was so close to the the wall
i felt a little disoriented because
there was no perspective there was no
point of relativity
and a lot of people experience this when
they ski or snowboard when the clouds
are low
and it sort of merges into the same tone
of the snow and you don't have any sort
of point of perspective there's no depth
perception
and it becomes very disorienting even
nauseating
and at that moment as i was stretching i
it just gave me the epiphany of my own
quote
that without diversity we don't know
oneness because
oneness doesn't have an experience